i am salsa ramon garcia professor of
obstetrics and gynecology at the
university of pennsylvania
it is my position that the oral
contraceptives when prescribed used and
supervised properly
present the function for which they were
designed
with
acceptable minimal morbidity
my name is louis lasagna i'm a clinical
pharmacologist from the johns hopkins
university school of medicine
in my opinion the unpleasant side
effects and the very real hazards
associated with the oral contraceptives
are of sufficient magnitude as to
constitute
a
a real deterrent to their use as a birth
control technique
i am sheldon siegel i am the director of
the biomedical division of the
population council at the rockefeller
university in new york
i shall act as moderator of the
discussion of this important and timely
topic
welcome to the exploration of concepts
and controversies in modern medicine one
of a series of programs dedicated to
examining the uncertain
candidly recognizing that much of
today's teaching is necessarily based
upon opinion and that the opinions of
eminent physicians in a given field vary
widely
the national medical audio visual center
believes that openly airing such
opposing views is a basic responsibility
of medical communications
dr sheldon siegel director population
council rockefeller university will act
as moderator of this presentation
american women are interested in oral
contraceptives
they are using these drugs at the rate
of over 2 500 tons a year
it is estimated that uh perhaps
one out of every three american women
married between the age of 15 and 44
has used or is using the oral
contraceptive
it is being prescribed by virtually
every physician in the country
on the other hand
we are well aware of the fact that women
using this drug
are not
normal with respect to many laboratory
parameters of
medical normalcy or of physiologic
function
we know for example that several of the
circulating hormones
are not within the normal range in women
using oral contraceptives
this refers to example to the
circulating levels of glucocorticoids
we are aware of the fact that there is
an evidence of altered carbohydrate
metabolism for women using oral
contraceptives at least a significant
percentage of them
there's also evidence of decreased liver
function as evidenced by
certain laboratory tests
how is it then
that in the face of this rather
perplexing enigma physicians continue to
prescribe the drug and feel that they
are doing so for the well-being of their
patients
these are some of the issues we would
like to explore we will first have a
statement from dr garcia
the
ease convenience and utter effectiveness
of the steroid contraceptives
is universally felt to distinguish it
from other forms of contraception
never before
in the history of the world have the
untoward effects
of pharmacological agents been so
consistently and so confusingly been
presented to a more sophisticated world
the clouding
these issues
are the fears of the unknown itself
criticisms from the
persons opposing contraception in any
form
and the bias of medical attitudes
the belief that pregnancy
is good
and not associated with hazards
and then
further moral issues are entertained
basically the education of physicians
uh imbues him
with the
philosophy the need to preserve life and
to avoid
harmful approaches
this
moreover extends is extended
to mean
that errors of our mission
are
less serious and
less ominous
than the errors
and the acts of commission
active contraception
because of this philosophy cannot be
uh favored
openly
the concept of health however
must consider the composite
of physical
mental
and social well-being
rather than the mere
absence
of infirmity and disease
the oil contraceptive by virtue of its
utter effectiveness
and the convenience which it entertains
contributes
to the health of the individual despite
the
many disadvantages that have been
pointed to it
the irresponsible adverse comments
about potential harmful effects
do not contribute to the health of the
individual
many of these accusations
have been made moreover
an unabated
population press
is also menacing
actions of the pill affect all body
systems to a greater or lesser degree
these actions are a resultant of the
combination
of the end results
of both direct effects on target organs
and as well as the indirect effects
which are mediated by alterations
induced in the endocrinologically active
areas
the
metabolic alterations
that have been discussed and pointed to
as occurring with the use of the oral
contraceptives have all been shown to be
to be reversible
when these agents are discontinued
many of the reported effects
are very difficult to classify as to
whether they are drug induced or
non-drug induced
causality and association
may not be synonymous
the epidemiologic studies of themselves
do not resolve
the matter convincingly
although there are massive data there
are no truly comparative studies
nor are the statistics of sufficient
validity to resolve the association and
causality controversy with absolutism
clinical judgment
is very much required
physicians cannot shirk their
responsibility
they must use care
and
continued supervision
in prescribing and then supervising and
caring for the subjects using this form
of contraception
there is no uh
effective no more effective approach to
contraception that can be pointed to and
prevention of pregnancy must be
considered an all or none principle the
purported risks of oral contraceptives
are of small incidents
and by and large
are outweighed by the inherent risks
associated with pregnancy and even the
toll of daily living
no pharmacological agents can be
considered to be totally safe
individual individuality is cherished
making the an ideal contraceptive
almost a uh
impossible to achieve
many more effective and convenient ones
are needed
dr lasagna would you make your opening
statement please
yes uh since the beginning of the
modern era of chemotherapy since the
time of paul ehrlich let us say
those interested in the development of
new chemicals have been searching for
magic bullets
for drugs that would pick out
the offending microorganism or would hit
a specific organ in the body and leave
relatively untouched
the rest of the body
leave the patient relatively unharmed
almost without exception perhaps without
exception one should say
uh this dream of a magic bullet has not
been fulfilled
drugs are more like buckshot than they
are like magic bullets
and the oral contraceptives in my
opinion illustrate this beautifully
as has been already said they seem to
hit almost every cell in the body with
each passing year we have become aware
of the ability of these chemicals
to affect many parts of the body
we have heard of changes in the skin
changes in the hair
alterations in libido not always in the
appropriate direction
we've heard of changes in the liver
disturbances in blood clotting with
thromboembolic phenomena manifesting
themselves in various parts of the body
we've heard of
depression
apparently associated in some women with
the use of the pill
we've heard of severe and excruciating
migraines headaches developing in some
women for the first time on starting
oral cancer
there is now beginning
to develop uh more and more of fear of
the potential for uh development of
cancer and either the breast or the
genital tract in women exposed for years
to these hormones
now when one takes all of those reports
and this buckshot
capacity of these powerful chemicals
and combines that with the knowledge
that
other methods
of contraception are available which
while not quite as effective as the oral
contraceptives are nevertheless in the
hands of many women extraordinarily
effective
i believe it's irresponsible for a
physician
to look upon
these pills
as
the method of first choice
for most or all women desiring birth
control
well we have a
interesting situation here in which
dr lasagna you believe that it's
irresponsible for physicians to be
prescribing the pill as the
contraceptive first choice and
you dr garcia believe that it's
irresponsible to be criticizing the
potential hazards of the pill
uh
i said
not for all women that's the method of
the first choice i believe it is the
method its first choice for someone
right
uh i i think that there probably uh
exists a
difficulty here in defining just what
the
the precise position of each uh
discussant is
perhaps i could help to
resolve this by asking two pointed
questions one to each of you
uh to you dr lasagna i would ask
do you believe that the oral
contraceptives as are now being used
should be withdrawn from the market
and to you dr garcia do you believe that
the safety of these drugs is adequate to
permit their widespread use without
medical prescription
yes while i have
for some years now been beating the
drums trying to alert people to the
possible hazards of the oil
contraceptives i have never and do not
today espouse the
position that these
uh predicaments should be removed from
the market i think they continue to play
a very important role
in birth control
there is no question
that the
controversy that exists
is really
not as deep
as would appear at first glance
on the one hand it's a matter of
how
one weighs out the relative merits there
is no question
that as i've indicated my opening
statement that the physician cannot
shirk his responsibility
uh he has to
supervise his patient adequately
completely he cannot just describe
the oral contraceptive nor can the oral
contraceptive be dispensed over the
counter nor in slot machines
there are sufficient
warnings
from the
studies and epidemiological reviews and
while they do not point with absolutism
i quite concur
that
these must not be left unheeded one must
continue
to review the problem
with this very much in mind however
the aspect
of
the hazards
of not taking the oral contraceptive
and when i say that not taking euro
contraceptive i am really referring to
not taking or not using
really effective methods of family
planning and when you get down below
six
pregnancy for 100 women years
you are dealing with
relatively
effective
methods above this
and the most of the methods that have
been evaluated at uh are not associated
with
the need for the physician
uh
are in the category of being relatively
ineffective
and when you're dealing with this as i
indicated also
the
need
for
considering
the philosophy that contraception is an
all-or-none principle and a woman comes
to me she doesn't want to be half safe
she wants to have complete protection
this is what she's asking for the
unwanted pregnancy
raises the great scepter
i think that here we have increases in
maternal
fetal mortalities we have increases in
other morbidities we have increased
hazards of the induced abortion itself
even under the best of hands there are
hazards with this approach
there are increases
in the
undesirable marriages that might result
without the availability of effective
conception
there are also the trauma and other
features with regard to
illegitimacy and the
increase in the undesirable
parental behavior towards the offspring
which are seen with great frequency
in our society today
dr garcia i don't think there's any
argument about the relative advantages
to the woman to the society at large
derived from the use of contraception i
think it sometimes is unfortunate that
people
consider as synonyms contraception on
the one hand and oral contraception on
the other many of the benefits in terms
of maternal health of which you speak
are derived from
virtually all effective contraception
and for women in many of our
socioeconomic classes
effective contraception includes not
only oral contraception but the
intelligent use of the diaphragm
the use of the intrauterine device and
in fact the intelligent use of the
method of periodic abstinence but i
think that uh from the response that
both of you made uh it's clear that uh
you have each weighed the the
equation of relative risk
and
benefit and come to the conclusion that
there is enough safety
in the use of oral contraceptions to
warrant the continuation of its uh use
in the uh in the country
uh so let us
focus now on the on the question of
these hazards and risks so that those in
the audience can make their own
judgments about the this balance of the
hazards on the one hand and the
effectiveness and usefulness on the
other i just respond first to
dr garcia's statement about women
wanting
100 protection i don't think all women
want 100 protection and i think this is
one of the reasons why there's a such a
tremendous variability in the reports in
the literature on the effectiveness of
such things as contents and diaphragms
i think the condom and the diaphragm
used compulsively
represents extraordinarily effective
techniques
but if you're casual about their use if
you uh
want a child or two sometime in the in
the future and don't really care all
that much whether it occurs a year from
now or
uh or two years from now
i think one has a different approach the
use of these mechanical devices than the
woman who has had four or five children
considers her family complete
and
is darn likely to be compulsive about
the use of these techniques
so that i i think in the interest of
individualizing our approach to these
women i think it would be unfortunate
to give the impression that every woman
one sees wants uh 100 perfection
furthermore if i can just complete my
thought
with the oral contraceptives one doesn't
have 100 percent protection
at least not with the sequential ones
which in my experience uh the number of
anecdotal reports i've come across
talking with patients with obstetricians
uh the failure rate is significant there
that protection is far from complete
well i i quite agree
that uh one has to individualize
however
there are again points that one might
take as issue here
uh
namely that the patient that has four or
five
pregnancies could likewise be
categorized as being in the upper age
group where she's going to fall within
the category of having greater risk of
taking the oral contraceptive so it's
not so simple matter and as a
gynecologist i don't know what your
experience is a clinical pharmacology
but as a gynecologist when i query my
patients they want an all or none sort
of reassurance
and very few of them elect to take
sequential modalities
can we pass now to the question of the
hazards themselves you pointed to dr
lasagna's uh
worldwide reputation as a clinical
pharmacologist so perhaps we should ask
him about some of these issues
that have been raised with respect to
the safety of the pill
let's take the cancer issue first where
does that stand and what are the real
facts in in that situation dr lasagna
i don't think there are a lot of heart
facts to go on here we have a long
background of experimental evidence
suggesting that hormones can be utilized
in
a number of animal models to produce
things like breast cancer that's clear
the relevance of these studies to the
use of these hormones uh in the variety
of clinical states in which they have
been used for a long time is unclear to
me
uh i think we're beginning to have
reports
on certain changes in
the cells of the cervix
that
make one at least
worry more than than
we've been worrying in the past and in
my
opinion at the moment the issue is an
open one uh
i think with the background that we have
on what these hormones can do in the
laboratory it would be
uh
foolish
to
assume that that we have no worries here
but i also would say that at the moment
the
uh evidence implicating these oral
contraceptives in the production of any
kind of cancer
is lacking
uh i think the evidence for example is
is much more compelling in regard to
traumatic disease
uh still for a moment on the cancer
issue uh on the basis of the animal work
isn't it more likely that the real
concern is the breast rather than the
cervix i think so yes
and uh have there been any uh clinical
observations or let me uh put it even
more fundamentally
has anyone actually done a study that
would give us some idea as to whether or
not there is a causal relationship i'm
not aware of any
it's it's a great pity i think that so
little attention has been paid
to the setting up of prospective studies
to monitor all these things that we're
concerned about and that we're we have a
hard time making definite statements
about because we're we're stuck with
retrospective analyses
you've been mostly involved with this
when attempts to set up prospective
studies have been uh
maybe at least the tries have been there
one of the greatest difficulties and one
of the things that
this is
new
to
most of the scientific world and
clinical
lines of investigation
that is to sample
a
denominator
that is as vast as is required to
measure
small changes in the numerator is indeed
a task that i don't know if it ever will
be accomplished or not with reference to
the oral contraceptive because there are
so many other factors that come into
the bias of selection and the like that
it's difficult to
do this and what's more
to try to have a truly controlled
population
that is not using the steroid
contraceptive versus a compassionate
theory concept was likewise very
difficult because the steroid
contraceptive group feel more compelled
because of the adverse ability to come
back to be seen more frequently
while those on other techniques
are much more difficult to follow and
this has been one of the greatest
pitfalls that we've had in trying to to
arrange for prospective studies i don't
know how to get around that well i think
that there are good epidemiologic
methods to account for this bias or to
take it into account in setting up the
design of a study
but
let me uh turn to another issue i think
the the one that has been most firmly
established among the possible serious
consequences of the use of oral
contraception has been uh the
epidemiologic studies and indications of
an increased risk
of thromboembolic disease associated
with the use of the drug studies both in
britain and now
on the basis of the recent report by the
advisory committee of citrix and
gynecology of the food and drug
administration confirmed here in the
united states
uh can you tell us how that stands and
what your view of that issue is dr
garcia
i i
that there is a
uh a strong
warning
that this presents
uh i don't know that this conclusively
proves
that there is a cause-and-effect
relationship and i think that as i
indicated previously epidemiological
views will not do this
they are still lacking many of the
mechanisms to explain
the
occurrence of these thromboembolic and
other effects
and until this gap has been bridged to
to demonstrate the mechanism of action
that will produce the effect
we still will not have a
cause-and-effect relationship but
nonetheless
these studies are very carefully
designed they're
been performed
according to
sound epidemiologic principles and
consistently although with different
variants of incidence and points of
comparison we have a concurrence with
all of the studies indicating an
association
between the use of oil contraceptives
and the occurrence of thrombophlebitis
and also consistently that this is seen
greater in the
older age group than in the younger age
i comment on the quality of the evidence
linking the contraceptives to oral
contraceptives to clotting
one thing i know something about is the
difficulty of linking drugs to to side
effects that are said to be associated
with them but in my opinion the evidence
on this point
is is so good
as to be
very compelling at least it's so much
better than we usually have for other
drugs that i think one can't ignore the
evidence the evidence exists in my
opinion not only in the form of
epidemiologic data but in the clotting
studies that have been done which in
almost all instances have shown a change
in women taking these pills in the
direction of increased clotting
the peculiar distribution of some of
these clots that are seen i mean women
coming in with with
clots in the veins of their arms the
most unusual phenomenon clots in the
vertebral arteries in young women a most
unusual neurological picture and then
the challenge cases the women who
develop recurrent thrombophlebitis each
time they're given the pill there aren't
a lot of those but there are enough i
think that to represent a legitimate
challenge
type of evidence
but this sort of bizarre type of
location of non-bombard phenomenon is
not new
it's just that it hasn't been focused
attention on in association with the use
of oral contraceptive number one and
secondly we have to also uh consider
that uh the
uh
i'm afraid not garcia i'm not gonna let
you finish your thought because our time
is up
uh
in a few seconds left to us i would like
to attempt a brief summary of this
discussion
it seems to me that we have reached a
consensus
that
this is a type of medication that does
involve risk
both participants agree that the risk is
not so great to warrant removal of these
drugs from the physician's armamentarium
i think that both agree also however
that when these drugs are used they must
be used under very careful supervision
and although the point wasn't raised
i feel confident that both would agree
that the
the labeling instructions required by
the food and drug administration should
be adhered to very strictly
as with all drugs there is a question of
relative risk versus relative advantage
in determining safety
on that basis and by that definition it
seems that there is an element of safety
sufficient for continuation of the use
of oral contraceptives
we thank dr salsa ramon garcia dr louis
lasagna and dr sheldon siegel for their
interesting analysis of a critical
problem in patient care
in subsequent programs we shall continue
to record equally significant concepts
and controversies in modern medicine
the opinions expressed on this program
do not necessarily constitute
endorsement by the department of health
education and welfare the public health
service or its constituents
you